hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about zinc
deficiency now what is zinc zinc is a
trace mineral it's basically a mineral
that's needed in a lot smaller amounts
but it's necessary because if you're
deficient you're going to have a lot of
different issues number one your sense
of smell will go away your sense of
taste will not be there you won't
actually be as hungry those are some
common symptoms white spots on the nails
you've got these little spots in the
nail but but usually what happened is
that you ate a lot of carbohydrate that
depleted the zinc because too much sugar
or carbohydrate will pull zinc out of
your body so if you had a little white
speck on the middle of your nail and by
the way that nail grows every six months
we knew about three months ago you had a
birthday party and you ate the whole
cake right so that's one way to
determining that okay now we have acne
skin issues Exuma all these skin issues
dermatitis could be related to zinc but
there's other things that can cause skin
issues too that almost mimic a zinc
deficiency like a vitamin A deficiency
or a vitamin b2 or b6 deficiency so
really you have to look at all of these
things to see what it is but I will say
that if you're low and zinc
you can't absorb or utilize vitamin A so
they always worked in bet gather with
like minerals work with vitamins
together and zinc is kind of like a main
mineral that's used in over 300 enzymes
so it's a lot of chemical body reactions
okay so with proteins and that brings us
to this one down here with hair alopecia
which is like little spots of hair
growth that's gone or thinning hair that
could be a B vitamin deficiency like
biotin but it can also be a zinc
deficiency as well they work together
okay then we have rhinoviruses well zinc
being a trace mineral helps put viruses
back in remission now the thing about
viruses you can't kill a virus because
it's not alive it's a piece of genetic
material that's wrapped in a sac that
can activate your own energy from your
cells and create a cascade of an immune
response so zinc is one that's
specific to actually keep the rhinovirus
in check and actually you can if you
take zinc when you're starting to get
sick it can speed up the time of
overcoming the sickness and actually can
prevent that issue as well but
rhinoviruses like the one that you of
the post nasal drip the sinus congestion
the sore throat the sneezing so you need
more zinc all right and then we have
lower testosterone both in male and
female if you have low testosterone your
libido will be very low okay that can
come from a zinc deficiency and then
mouth ulcers again that can come from
other things but that little sore on the
inside of the mouth which is usually
virus related the viruses like herpes it
can come out of remission if you're
under stress and because the zinc
becomes deficient so sugar and stress
will deplete the zinc reserves okay
because more cortisol pumps out and then
it needs zinc to use the for the immune
system and then basically deplete your
zinc reserves so it's involved in a lot
of different enzymes now it's in oysters
that has a lot of zinc from the sea of
course and then it's in animal like beef
it's in pork it's in red meat it's also
in seek help it's in a lot of foods but
it's really high in these foods right
here and also zinc actually helps make
the red white blood cell so the adrenal
gland controls the white blood cells
suppresses the immune system and that's
and zinc is involved in that whole
process so we have a relationship
between countering stress having the
trace minerals to make sure that your
immune system is strong okay so here are
just and lastly I'm going to talk about
in other countries like not in America
but third world countries a lot of
children and infants will die because of
a zinc deficiency because they have
diarrhea and so you know zinc is
unfortunately they don't put it back in
the soils so it could be a factor of
it's either not in your food because
it's not in the soil it could be you're
trying to get your zinc from grains but
not a
there's a certain hibbett ER for zinc
and other minerals called phytic acid in
grains so that chemical in the grain
naturally prevents the absorption of
minerals okay and then also your if your
stomach acid is not strong enough you're
not going to pull that acid in too so if
you have heartburn you have GERD
indigestion chances are you're zinc
deficient just from that alone okay so
there's a lot of different aspects of
zinc I wanted to cover some of them but
there's a lot more but I hope this
helped and I will see you in the next
video